День виборів у Німеччині уже прозвали
«виборчим землетрусом».
Пласти політичного ландшафту помітно зсунулися,
якщо вірити результатам екзит-полів.
Партія Анґели Меркель втратила чимало прихильників,
утім це не завадило їй стати переможницею цих виборів.
Четвертий строк на посаді канцлерки Меркель забезпечено.
Ми уповноважені сформувати уряд.
І проти нас не може бути сформовано уряду.
Виборчий землетрус сильно вдарив по соціал-демократах.
Вони досягли власного історичного дна –
впали до близько 20-ти відсотків.
Такої поразки тут, у штабі, не очікували.
Сьогодні важкий і сумний день для німецької соціал-демократії.
Скажу відверто: ми не досягли нашої виборчої цілі.
Соціал-демократи можуть сформувати коаліцію
із політсилами Меркель,  утім одразу ж після виборів заявили,
що віддають перевагу опозиційному табору.
Інакше опозицію очолила би правопопулістська
«Альтернатива для Німеччини», яка палко святкує
свою першу парламентську перемогу і оголошує прямим текстом
"полювання на Меркель".
Ми будемо "полювати" на пані Меркель
чи на кого б там не було.
Така риторика на ура сприймається в таборі АдН.
Правопопулісти стануть третьою найбільшою
силою в парламенті, але працювати з ними ніхто не хоче.
До урядування їм шлях закритий так само, як і Лівим.
Тож найімовірніша коаліція у новому парламенті –
союз ХДС/ХСС на чолі з Меркель,
Зелені та Вільні демократи.
Нова коаліція означає і призначення нового міністра закордонних справ.
Ним може стати або представник Зелених,  що дружні до України.
Або вільних демократів, які були готові до поступового
зняття санкцій з Росії в обмін на примирення на Донбасі.
Утім, і за соціал-демократа Зіґмара Ґабріеля,
партія якого також виступає за поступове скасування санкцій,
в українському питанні переважав курс Меркель.
Погана новина для України на цих німецьких виборах -
табір партій, які сповідують лояльну політику до Росії,
суттєво побільшав.
Чотири із шести сил-переможців
більшою чи меншою мірою виявляли лояльність до Кремля.
Хороша новина полягає в том, що друзями України
та різкими критиками Кремля в німецькому парламенті залишаються Зелені.
А допоки країною керує Анґела Меркель,
урядовий курс в питаннях дипломатичного врегулювання
конфлікту на Донбасі, збереження санкцій щодо Кремля
та невизнання анексії Криму
не повинен змінитися.